the past isn't dead  james fate draws us back together  now your enemies my enemy  his name is saffin and what does he want  revenge me when her secret finds its way  out  it'll be the death of you  you can imagine why i've come back to  play  there's a young lady in santiago i want  you to meet you're late  when you're ready  salute i met your new double-oh  she's a disarming young woman i get why  you shot him  yeah well everyone tries at least once  james bond  we both eradicate people  to make the world a better place i just  want to be a little  tidier  come on bond where the hell are you  harder to tell the good from bad  villains from heroes these days  what is it you don't know what this is  he's going to kill millions  if we don't do this  there will be nothing left to say  [Music]  you